GOOD NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
AT THE CORE OF ANY POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN IS THE MESSAGE OF WHAT
IT'S ABOUT.
WHAT EXACTLY ARE NEXT TUESDAY'S
MIDTERM ELECTIONS ABOUT?
ON THE ONE SIDE IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR, DONALD TRUMP WHO IS THE
LEADER OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
AND IN FACT, IT'S ONLY
SPOKESMAN, SAYS THAT ABOUT FOUR
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES IS A VOTE
FOR SECURE BORDERS AND AGAINST
CRIME AND CHAOS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT WHEN HE SAYS THIS BUT
THAT'S DEFINITELY WHAT
REPUBLICANS ARE RUNNING ON.
WHAT ARE DEMOCRATS RUNNING ON,
AGAINST TRUMP CERTAINLY.
HE TALKS ABOUT HIS PRESIDENT
EVEN MORE THAN HE TALKS ABOUT
HIMSELF.
THEY DON'T LIKE HIM AT ALL.
FINE.
BUT DESPISING SOMEONE ISN'T
REALLY A PLATFORM OR PATH
FORWARD, AT BEST IT'S A
REACTION.
WHAT ARE THE IDEAS THAT UNITE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY RIGHT NOW?
FOR THE ANSWER TO THAT WE GO TO
THE OTHER CABLE STATIONS WHICH
FOR THEM THE PAST COUPLE YEARS
HAVE COME TO FUNCTION MUCH AS
THE DNC.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT
DEMOCRATS ARE THINKING WATCH CNN
AND MSNBC.
LAST NIGHT WAS ESPECIALLY
INSTRUCTIVE.
HERE ARE TWO CONTRIBUTORS TO
MSNBC.
ONE WRITES FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ON THE
OTHER AT PRINCETON WHICH IS AN
IVY LEAGUE COLLEGE IN
NEW JERSEY.
BOTH HAVE IMPRESSIVE CREDENTIALS
AND BOTH ARE CONSIDERED DEEP
THINKERS BY MOST OF THE OTHER
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY WHO THINK
OF THEMSELVES AS INTELLECTUALS.
WATCH AS THEY EXPLAINED WHAT
THEY HAVE LEARNED SINCE THE 2016
ELECTION.
>> WHAT I DID WRONG IN 2016 AS I
OVERESTIMATED WHITE PEOPLE.
I DIDN'T THINK WHITE PEOPLE
WOULD PUT HIM IN OFFICE.
>> I'M NOT WILLING TO LET WHITE
VOTERS OFF THE HOOK.
I THINK THERE ARE A LARGE
NUMBER, I WOULD SAY THE MAJORITY
OF WHITE AMERICANS IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO ARE NOT JUST
DEMOCRATS BUT PEOPLE OF
CONSCIENCE, WHO ARE GOOD
AMERICANS.
I BELIEVE THAT THEY NEED TO MOVE
FROM SAYING, WELL, I DON'T LIKE
HIS TWEETS BUT THE ECONOMY IS
DOING OKAY.
THEY NEED TO MOVE FROM THERE TO
REALITY WHICH IS THAT WE HAVE A
WHITE NATIONALIST PRESIDENT WITH
A THREAT TO AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
>> Tucker: NOW THERE WAS A
TIME NOT SO LONG AGO WHEN
LANGUAGE LIKE THIS WAS
CONSIDERED TEXTBOOK RACE HATRED
EVEN BY LIBERAL DEMOCRATS.
YOU WEREN'T ALLOWED TO BLAME
ENTIRE RACES OF PEOPLE FOR
ANYTHING.
IF YOU WEREN'T EVEN SUPPOSED TO
THINK OF YOUR FELLOW AMERICANS
PRIMARILY IN TERMS OF THEIR RACE
AND SKIN COLOR IS ONE THING THAT
CAN'T CONTROL.
WHAT MATTERS IS THE CONTENT OF A
PERSON'S CHARACTER.
BUT NOT ANYMORE.
NOW THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE,
IDENTITY IS EVERYTHING.
HERE IS DON LEMON ON MONDAY
NIGHT.
>> WE HAVE TO STOP DEMONIZING
PEOPLE AND REALIZED THE BIGGEST
TERROR THREAT IN THIS COUNTRY IS
A WHITE MEN, MOST OF THEM
RADICALIZED TO THE RIGHT, AND WE
HAVE TO START DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT THEM.
THERE IS NO TRAVEL BAN ON THEM.
THERE IS NO BAN ON, THEY HAD THE
MUSLIM BAN, THERE IS NO WHITE
GUY BAN.
SO WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT THAT?
>> WE HAVE TO START DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT THEM, THESE
PEOPLE A CERTAIN SKIN COLOR.
THAT'S WHAT DON LEMON SAID.
BEFORE YOU GET TOO OUTRAGED
ABOUT THAT AND STOP WATCHING HIS
SHOW EVERY NIGHT, KEEP IN MIND
THAT DON LEMON IS A CABLE NEWS
HOST, ON TELEVISION FIVE HOURS
PER WEEK.
LIVE.
HE'S BOUND TO SAY SOMETHING
INDEFENSIBLE EVERY ONCE IN A
WHILE, WE ALL DO.
HERE ARE THE RULES.
WHEN YOU SAY SOMETHING AWFUL
THAT YOU CAN'T DEFEND, DON'T TRY
TO DEFEND IT.
APOLOGIZE AND EXPLAIN WHAT YOU
MEANT AND MOVE ON.
VOWED TO DO BETTER.
THAT'S A RULE FOR LIFE, NOT JUST
TELEVISION NEWS.
ON THE LEFT THOUGH IT NO LONGER
APPLIES.
HERE'S WHAT DON LEMON SAID LAST
NIGHT ABOUT HIS REMARKS ON
MONDAY.
>> THE BIGGEST TERROR THREAT IN
THIS COUNTRY COMES FROM RADICALS
ON THE FAR RIGHT, PRIMARILY
WHITE MAN.
THAT ANGERED SOME PEOPLE.
THEIR ANALYSIS SHOWS FOR EVERY
EIGHT DEADLY ATTACKS BY WHITE
RING EXTREMISTS, THERE WERE ONE
BY LEFT-WING EXTREMISTS.
THOSE ARE THE FACTS.
PEOPLE WHO WERE ANGERED ABOUT
WHAT I SAID ARE MISSING THE
ENTIRE POINT.
WE DON'T NEED TO WORRY ABOUT
PEOPLE THAT ARE THOUSANDS OF
MILES AWAY.
THE BIGGEST THREATS ARE
HOMEGROWN.
>> Tucker: IF YOU DIDN'T LIKE
WHAT I SAID, THAT'S YOUR
PROBLEM.
YOU NOTICE THE LACK OF
CONTRITION WHEN DON LEMON SAID
WE HAVE TO START DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT AMERICANS OF A CERTAIN
SKIN COLOR, IT TURNS OUT IT
WASN'T A MISTAKE, HE MEANT THAT.
HE DIDN'T APOLOGIZE BECAUSE
NOBODY IN HIS WORLD ASKED THEM
TO AND THEY ARE ALL SAYING
PRETTY MUCH THE SAME THING.
THIS IS A COMMON VIEW IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, ONE OF THE
THINGS THEY ARE RUNNING ON.
LOTS OF AMERICANS WON'T LIKE
THAT OBVIOUSLY BUT DEMOCRATS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
THEY NO LONGER CARE ABOUT WHAT
THOSE OF YOU CAN STINK.
THAT'S WHY THEY FIGHT HARDER TO
PROVIDE BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP
FOR FARMERS THAN THEY EVER
THOUGHT TO PROTECT AMERICAN
CITIZENS FROM PLUNGING
MIDDLE-CLASS WAGES OR PRIVACY
DESTROYING TECH MONOPOLY       M
DESTROYING TECH MONOPOLY       N
DESTROYING TECH MONOPOLY       P
DESTROYING TECH MONOPOLY       L
DESTROYING TECH MONOPOLY       E
DESTROYING TECH MONOPOLY       .
YOU ALREADY KNOW ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS OF DEMAND THAT AMERICA
IGNORE ITS OWN IMMIGRATION LAWS,
BUT IT'S GONE FAR BEYOND THAT.
ELIZABETH WARREN WHO IS THE
CENTER FOR MASSACHUSETTS HAS
CONDEMNED OUR ENTIRE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AS A RACIST.
MEANWHILE, BETO O'ROURKE AGREES
WITH THAT AND BECAUSE OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM THE NEW JIM CROW.
HE ACCUSES COPS OF SHOOTING
PEOPLE BASED ON THEIR SKIN
COLOR.
HE OFFERED NO EVIDENCE THAT COPS
DO THAT, BECAUSE HE JUST KNOWS
IT'S TRUE.
MEANWHILE, LAWS AGAINST CRIME
LIKE SHOPLIFTING AND PUBLIC AND
OTHERS CAN NO LONGER BE ENFORCED
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE RACIST.
THE RESULT OF ALL OF THIS IS
INEVITABLE.
MORE CRIME, AND YOU ARE SEEING
THAT IN MANY PLACES.
TURNS OUT THE VICTIMS ARE NOT
CLOISTERED RICH PEOPLE LIKE BETO
OR ROURKE, THEY ARE NORMAL
PEOPLE OF ALL RACES.
CRIME HURTS EVERYONE BUT IT
TENDS TO HURT THE POOR THE MOST.
IF THAT HAS OCCURRED TO
DEMOCRATS THEY HAVEN'T MENTIONED
IT.
THEY KNOW THEY ARE LIKELY TO WIN
BACK THE HOUSE ON TUESDAY AND
THEY ARE FEELING VINDICATED, OR
SELF-RIGHTEOUS THAN EVER.
WE SEARCHED LONG AND HARD TODAY
FOR A PIECE OF TAPE THAT COULD
SUM UP THE DEMOCRATIC WORLDVIEW
RIGHT NOW AND WE FOUND THIS.
IT WAS SHOT BY A NETWORK CAMERA
MAN COVERING THE PRESIDENT'S
TRIP TO THE TREE OF LIFE OF LIFE
SYNAGOGUE IN PITTSBURGH THIS
WEEK.
THE PROTESTERS SCREAMING AT THE
PRESIDENT HAPPENS TO BE A
PRESBYTERIAN MINISTER.
WATCH.
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT YOU.
LET THE FAMILIES GRIEVE, THIS IS
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
YOU ARE NOT WELCOME HERE.
YOU DON'T BELONG HERE.
THIS IS OUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
WE WELCOME EVERYBODY HERE.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE NOT WELCOME
HERE!
WE WELCOME EVERYBODY.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH THE WHOLE
DEMOCRATIC MESSAGE RIGHT THERE.
WILL IT WORK?
MAYBE ON TUESDAY OR MAYBE FOR A
LITTLE WHILE.
ANGELO MERKEL TRIED IT, BUT
ULTIMATELY THEIR COUNTRY HAS
REJECTED THAT.